welcome to transcriptomics to this
course builds upon transcriptomics one
where we learned about the processing of
high-throughput sequencing data you can
find all of our transcriptomics courses
in the RNA seek election on the edu t--
bio info site transcriptomics - is the
second course in the introductory series
here we will focus on finding
significant differences in gene
expression patterns we will start with
differential gene expression and
continue to look at typical challenges
that can be resolved using statistical
methods we will look at hypothesis
testing p-values false discovery rate
and then use D SEC - and edge our
methods for differential gene expression
analysis next we will explore more
complex variation in the gene expression
by using factor regression models as a
result you will learn how to detect
obvious differences between preset
groups of samples as well as use
regression to identify the expression
level variation associated with
experimental design factors in the first
transcriptomics course we learned about
processing short reads and converting
them into a table of expression the
table has genes for rows and samples for
columns in each cell there is a number
corresponding to the level of expression
for this gene in a given sample in the
gene expression table we can find genes
that are expressed at different levels
and samples in order to study a
condition such as breast cancer type we
need to see how the gene expression data
can explain these conditions
differentially expressed genes are the
ones we can identify to have a clear
difference in expression levels between
the two groups here you can see that the
ENS G gene listed at the top of the
graphic has a higher expression level in
the triple negative group compared to
the ER positive group there are several
factors that make it difficult to
identify differentially expressed genes
first there are thousands of gene in
each sample samples in each group can
have significant variation in expression
levels and even when there's a
difference that we've observed it's hard
to know what will be significant enough
to say that these are truly
differentially expressed genes to
overcome these challenges we have to
turn the statistical analysis
William Gossett was a statistician who
worked for the Guinness beer brewing
company he earned a degree in chemistry
at Oxford and joined the brewing firm in
1899 his work for Guinness led him to
investigate the validity of results
obtained from small samples previous
Theory had concentrated instead on large
samples
Gossett's most important result was
known as the students t-test of
distribution published in 1908 a t-test
is a type of inferential statistic used
to determine if there is a significant
difference between the means of two
groups the t-test is used as a
hypothesis testing tool which allows
testing of an assumption applicable to a
population the p-value is often used in
statistics and represents an unlikely
observation to happen by chance a
significant t-test result is one in
which the difference between groups is
unlikely to have occurred because the
sample happened to be a typical
statistical significance suggests that
the two larger populations from which we
sample are quote unquote actually
different another point we have to
consider in our example is the number of
genes in each sample this issue is
called family-wise error rate there are
a number of approaches to address the
unreliable nature of p-values in cases
with a large number of observations when
multiple testing happens most of the
approaches attempt to assign the
adjusted p-value to each test to reduce
the p-value threshold from 5% to a more
reasonable value the false discovery
rate approach is a more recent
development this approach also
determines adjusted p-values for each
test however it controls the number of
false discoveries in those tests that
result in a discovery such as a
significant result because of this it is
less conservative than the bonferroni
approach and has great ability to find
truly significant results these methods
can also be used manually but many are
included in the standard output of
differential expression analysis
packages one way to use differential
expression analysis is to add it to the
end of a full RNA seek processing
pipeline
another way is to use the gene
expression table to directly run dc2 or
edge our packages independently in the
course you will have a chance to
practice this pipeline as well as see
the analysis results the results will
include the original and adjusted
p-values for each gene in the course we
will also talk about factor regression
analysis that uses regression to study a
number of factors influencing the
expression levels of each gene we will
talk about regression correlation and
how to understand this powerful approach
to study gene expression data in our
example we will have two factors cancer
type and mouse type we will also learn
how to set up a pipeline using these
factors and levels to conduct factor
regression analysis as a result we can
turn the biological interpretation of
found genes and learn about gene
function in the context of differential
gene expression or the factors we found
to be associated with a certain
expression pattern transcriptomics 2 is
the course that will help you identify
the links between gene expression and
phenotypes let's start learning